we talked to gay and lesbian scientists
and asked for their advice to young
LGBTQ people interested in pursuing a
career in stem you're welcome in science
and engineering and there are
communities of people who will help make
sure that you find that sense of
welcoming and inclusion see your
identity as an advantage see it as a way
for you to be able to think creatively
about the world in which you inhabit
that people who don't share your
identity characteristics might not be
able to see so we don't want to lose out
on having lgbtqia+ people in stem
bringing those unique perspectives as
well as people of color as well as
people from first-generation and
low-income backgrounds people with
disabilities need all those folks and
all the intersections of those
communities working in stem to be able
to solve these big challenges that
humanity faces and to do some really
great curiosity driven science just to
further human knowledge research is
about collaboration and if people don't
trust you they're not going to want to
collaborate or have you as a colleague
so being out actually it's an advantage
that you are open and authentic some of
the general guiding principles that I
learned through trial and error isn't
undergrad were to explore many different
realms of the sciences as well as the
humanities to really try and craft for
myself a liberal education so that way
whatever scientific Avenue I decided to
pursue had really great context and
that's proved invaluable and how I
proceed as a scientist and also made me
able to talk with people from all
different fields and that became really
important as a queer person because I
got to then meet queer people in all
other different fields and build that
it's queer network that I now have at
times when there wasn't another low
temperature surface process geochemist
studying first where transition metals
who was also a gay man maybe there was
someone else who did
something similar but in a different
discipline you had an experience of the
queer community to guide me by staying
in these fields you could become a role
model yourself just showing up as who
you are you are doing some of this work
to raise visibility and smooth the
pathway further for more people who want
to enter these fields that my advice is
always be yourself don't settle pursue
your goals no matter whether or not you
think you're the only one because
there's plenty more people like you and
we're all here to help you move forward
take pride in the ideas that you have
and don't be afraid to be out there and
follow follow your dreams be proud